hi there I'm Walter Bernays yak and this
is top five here we countdown the best
and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we take a look at
the worst of jail aw yeah that's right
Jennifer Lawrence this top-5 is the
result of a Twitter poll I put up asking
who should be the first actress covered
on top five if you want your voice heard
make sure you follow me on Twitter and
awesome underscore Walter for more polls
the 26 year old megastar has a great
young career going for herself with one
Oscar win and several nominations
however there have been a couple
missteps on her road to success so
without further ado here are j-law top 5
worst performances that's the last time
I'll say Jayla the girl's name is
Jennifer Lawrence number 5 Alissa
Cassidy in house at the end of the
street Warren starred in this horror
movie the same year the first Hunger
Games movie came out and they push back
the release of this film a couple months
so it was pretty commercially successful
actually came in at number 1 on its
opening weekend however the film is
pretty generic for the genre and
Lawrence couldn't do much to save it
with their performance Sarah is a
divorcee who moves to a small town with
her daughter Alyssa to start anew
however a house nearby has only one
resident that the small town doesn't
like that resident is a young man named
Ryan years earlier Ryan's sister Carrie
Anne murdered their parents and
disappeared when Alyssa starts a
relationship with Ryan what really
happened to his family is revealed in
shocking ways Jennifer Lawrence isn't
the only Jennifer in this movie why
didn't you call me I would have come to
get you had to Lawrence does her best
with material given to her house at the
end of the street it's a pretty bland by
the numbers horror film that doesn't do
much to set it apart from the pack a
performance like this usually wouldn't
be on this list but with Lawrence's
limited filmography I had to choose
something for the number 5 spot her
character is an aspiring singer but it's
obviously not her voice in those scenes
and it's pretty noticeable now that
we've heard her sing in one of the
Hunger Games Movies apparently she did
record her songs but the filmmakers used
another
be sweet if you could be
this character pushes things along in
her interactions with those around her
especially with her mom and Ryan those
scenes don't come off very well and they
stick out a bit my mom went to a
psychiatrist for a long time after she
broke up with my dad I like the way you
see things I like the way you see me
like the movie she's just kind of boring
here things do pick up a bit at the end
but it's subpar for what we know she
could do at this point number four
mystique / Raven dark hole in x-men Days
of Future past
Lawrence's mystique has become an easy
target for people pointing out that she
doesn't care about these movies and I
will say there are a few moments here
when her disinterest is visible in the
1970s dr. Bolivar Trask creates the
Sentinels giant robots that can detect
the mutant gene and destroy them you're
a smart man in the 21st century those
sentinels are now highly advanced
murdering machines that have wiped out
almost all of mutant kind as the
remaining x-men fight for survival
Wolverine is sent back into the 1970s to
change how the Sentinels are created and
avoid this dark disturbing and
catastrophic future
I like Lawrence's mystique in x-men
first class the character was more
energetic and she seemed to put more
into it between first class and Days of
Future past she became one of the
biggest stars in the world and honestly
doesn't need the x-men movies anymore
her current persona doesn't even match
up with being in a superhero movie right
now or at that time especially this role
in this series while I really like Days
of Future past maybe my favorite x-men
movie making her the center point of
this whole plot seemed obviously only
done because of who she is now if there
were no Hunger Games and she didn't
become as huge as she is I think her
role in these movies would have been
reduced the emotional scenes with her
packed no real punch
just because an actor can cry on command
doesn't mean it holds any weight when
the performance behind it just isn't
there she was doing bigger things and
was the main part of a hotter franchise
so if she was disinterested especially
with putting on all that blue makeup
it showed number three mystique / rave
dark home in x-men apocalypse again due
to a lack of more roles I thought it was
okay to put two of her mystique
performances on this list and she's a
decent amount worse than this than she
was in Days of Future past in 1983 the
father of all mutants apocalypse is
woken from his slumber he then recruits
his four mutant horsemen and begins his
attempt to tear down this weak new world
he's discovered and build a better wad
the only one standing in his way are the
newly reformed x-men led by Professor
Charles Xavier
after Days of Future past x-men
apocalypse left something to be desired
Lawrence is once again a big focus here
but now the movie around here doesn't
have all that much going for it not that
there isn't some good strong stuff
packed in there but all-in-all
x-men apocalypse is just barely above
average mystique is like a folk hero to
mutants all over the world now after the
ending of the last film she's reluctant
to accept this point of view others have
of her and seems more apathetic than
ever and Lawrence's third goal round as
the character it was pretty much
confirmed by Lawrence herself that this
was her last x-men movie the combination
of that makeup and ostensibly not being
into the x-men projects made for a
predictable parting of the ways what
makes her worse here is just more of the
same but now it's a little more blatant
that she just doesn't want to be there
you got your warplane let's go to war
your x-men
I'm sure she's relieved to put this role
behind her and move on to other projects
that suit her needs as an actor a little
bit better
number two Serena Pemberton in Serena
never heard of this movie you're not
alone and never had a big theatrical
release in the u.s. despite having two
of the biggest movie stars in the world
as its leads why is that not sure but I
can tell you that this movie isn't very
good and Laurence is just about as bland
as ever in it based on a 2008 Ron rash
novel Serena follows the story of George
Pemberton an ambitious timber baron who
works in depression-era North Carolina
when George meets Serena Shaw they
quickly Wed and run his business
together
Serena soon miscarries and this creates
intense jealousy towards the mother of
George's illegitimate young son that
results in a dark turn for all involved
Lawrence has just flat throughout this
film her line delivery is pretty draw
and this character isn't the best fit
for our love began the day we met
nothing that happened before even
existed I have a child inside me as the
movie goes along Lawrence's performance
picks up a little bit but the movie is
very slow to get to things that we all
know are coming by the time her big
scenes come around there isn't much she
does that we haven't seen her do better
in other movies I do admit it was good
to see Varys from Game of Thrones in
this though my father had 40,000 acres
in Colorado and I do hope he didn't lose
him in this awful crash I'm a good actor
my hood this was a rare dramatic misfire
by Lawrence if you want to see it for
yourself it's on Netflix so check it out
on there and the number one worst
Jennifer Lawrence performance is Mariana
in the burning plane when people talk
about Jennifer Lawrence looking bored in
her films I direct you to this 2009 film
here the film tells two interconnected
stories Sylvia is a successful
restaurant owner who leads a private
life of promiscuity and self-hatred when
a man shows up with a young girl who
supposedly still be his daughter things
quickly change for elsewhere
a girl named Mariana and a boy named
Santiago begin a relationship when they
find out that his father and her
having an affair as the two stories
progressed unexpected twists are brought
to light Lawrence isn't exactly the main
focus in this movie but she does have a
pretty sizable role Kim Basinger and
Charlize Theron take up the top billing
at that time canvass one only if you
give me the scar what I want to remember
this day I love it
her character is very reserved but to
the point where you're not sure if she's
even invested in the slightest
seeing Mariana investigate her mother's
infidelity also manages to be dull I'm
not sure if it was the direction or just
Lawrence herself not being engaged but
thus far I think it's pretty clear that
Mariana in the burning plane is her
worst performance this is just an odd
film with very strange character
motivations for all involved it's not
very well known and I think it's
something that Lawrence probably wants
to keep in the past she's a great
actress in a career just keeps growing
as she continues to take on more
complicated characters and challenging
roles I want to hear what you guys think
what is your least favorite Jennifer
Lawrence role and/or performance what do
you want me to cover next on the show
leave a comment and let me know if you
haven't already make sure to go back and
check out my top 5 best Jennifer
Lawrence performances follow me on
Twitter at awesome underscore Walter to
take part in more polls about who may be
covered next on the show and come back
next week for a brand new top 5 I think
you'll like the next subject you
probably never had a friend like him
you